welcome everyone to the 2015 Shing field  cup what are your feelings about playing  in this in this city and in the same  field but I'm very glad to be here rocky  are with your cape and now my Marisa  player well first of all I'd like to  repeat what just visit the last year I  was here as a spectator but now the  power you've been the player of the year  so far in my opinion you've had  fantastic results after fantastic result  first of all Maurice thanks for saying  I've played the best shot I actually  don't play that I think I did say you  play the best chess I just said you had  great results all right a great honor  for me the you asking me some questions  because i'm a big fan of yours oh I hope  maybe in one game you will say that our  British troops attack is growing up is  open it isn't baby stuff